how the gun rest my name
bring back welcome back to some ghost
hunting
hello Haruki hello Harold you got a
hunch I'm go down of course we are in
case you're not too scared or anything
cars I'm not just get I'm talking to the
audience my brows all right Christ they
are not afraid of this last episode of
freakin terrifying I hate those little
things coming out of that
alright hurricane you're on my side
whenever hurt key goes red that means
you from just simply [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
so we will try not to get [ __ ] in the
bunch what what oh no there you go there
go hurry shh shh I'm sorry pet I'm
freaking out oh [ __ ] her game don't
judge it out Sheila I'm freaking out you
uh Holly shooters all right it's gone
here
I just take a shout out calm down Shh
rainbow rainbow rainbow rainbows rainbow
there we go there we go I'm okay I feel
better now no no no no no no no rainbows
rainbows rainbows rainbows rainbows a
much holy [ __ ] calm down
all right so the first skull is over
here I guess we can get it on the way
back or something
I'll put you there on it what's that it
goes there
all right and think so no one dares to
[ __ ] with me and her
I'm Scalia that's pity alright so that's
a dead end
I guess I didn't hear anything all right
let's go back why should I
shh-shh-shh calm down herkie it's just
oh cool we can go here Wow I yourself
back sigh crying baby babies are not Shh
calm down I know you don't like babies
[ __ ] eaters man I don't like them I
don't watch shh shh
calm down Erica calm down hurricane
she's all gonna be all right it's all
gonna be fine
why do
what is that hello and one their psyche
did you see anyone I don't know either I
think before the [ __ ] there I came in my
watch what place I seriously would have
killed myself if I was here alone I'm so
glad you're here her key what
whoa someone laughing it's not funny
it's not what someone there
whoa hello no okay [ __ ] you
hazel spank Bob oh she how the lag
wasn't it whoa hanky panky No get off oh
thank heavens ah Martha Oh party you
nearly died I can't be down here oh you
freaked the [ __ ] out of me okay don't be
a [ __ ] pity this is not Posie I'm
totally fine with this all right what is
this can start this I want to open that
door over there oh man oh [ __ ] man
all right I don't even know what yeah
thank you
I don't know about your situation man I
just don't know anymore
just [ __ ] babies man
Shh everyone just calm the [ __ ] down and
we'll be out of here in no time
okay I know you're scared I know you're
scared I know you're scared I get it
I cried get it cause frankly I don't get
anything what is this place anyway I
don't get it are you in there okay
okay just calm the [ __ ] down
everything's gonna be on you want me to
sing for you yes pretty please what you
want to be here well I don't think now
it's the time for anything did anyone
turn off the lights okay well I don't
really like this sentiment in there
that's scholarly all right come back
ego's man whoa set eyes
oh no oh no okay this [ __ ] I need a
power generator to go in there I don't
really get my turn
can I go in here yeah it looks like it
is need the crowbar I guess I had it the
last time I forget why I don't have it
this time
alright let's see if I can cheat or
something
can I pick this up I should be able to
pick these up yeah
alright you can jump over it or
something
Shh there we go
how didn't even need the box all right
Harry Gillis venture further whoa what
the [ __ ] I saw someone what oh I don't
like this no me gustan no me gusta all
right I see why would the [ __ ] is that a
skull all right
purple skull bash around whoa whoa whoa
what's that
all right Kerry math can read man no you
can good face I have ten
Shh don't get down don't build someone
there what the [ __ ]
thought I saw someone Wow sick of this
[ __ ] oh no I gotta go back to save her
key
see ya watch Annette all right how long
am i six minutes I didn't mean
definitely and I'm gonna have to say all
right I'll see you in a couple of
seconds for you for me a couple [ __ ]
minutes in hell but that's cool no one
cares
cashton fiiming Trumbo all you brothers
want just can't damage they take fun
food all right forgot about that one Shh
bow don't you hurt me no more bodies
barrels uh-huh Jerri be don't hurt me
don't hurt me no more dead dead dead
dead dead dead [ __ ] off all of you just
[ __ ] the [ __ ] up dad dad dad
dirt dirt dirt dirt dirt [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out all right see I apparently need to
take the why the hell am i why the
fru-u-- curse on the duker all right I
don't know where the [ __ ] I am
I miss her key that's all I know that's
just all I know right now her key
he and I we're living on a crazy side
and then we thought like oh wow
and someone's in the movie I don't know
what it's calling is maybe shut there
there's something it's like a bunch of
girls going in a mine and it was kind of
like this I don't like this
not one [ __ ] [ __ ] all right okay
it's cool that's cool it's cool it's
totally fine it's no monsters in here
just just ghosts I wanted to kill me
that's cool yeah I like this situation
have the penetration that's what my mom
always no she did not say that
hey lamp who put you there something
that make them feel more safe okay the
hell am i anyway where is this place
huh I need to break those I think I need
to break those nice but why can't I open
the console Yo no comprendo
all right I have a [ __ ] camera how
about that oh there we go
all right I want something I need a
[ __ ] share to chill out
all right probably stupid idea I'm not
cheating this is totally legit skills
that I'm doing transportation I just I
just need a gun or something Oh dynamite
make him blow it up damage alright put
you there and they are and how do I make
them explode oh I have a good night
alright
they should explode
oh whoa what the [ __ ] is that
I'm out of here whoa it's box oh it's
just oh okay I get it I wasn't even
supposed to go there okay what the [ __ ]
happened it's just an Indian graveyard
thing which I don't really a big fan of
Doge
no sir I know why I did all this I'm
gonna have to do it I just have to walk
here I'm so sick whoa what was that
all right kids keep going I guess [ __ ]
was that I wasn't even doing anything oh
[ __ ] me all right I'll just I'm just
gonna go in here and then we'll see you
about the rest no actually I'm not gonna
go and what the hell is this I just
wanna go back I just want to go back
right now I'll save here and then I'll
she pick up next okay that's pretty much
it
but my charge to find a backup biggest
hit high in the bow
now what are you doing [ __ ]
you're not to catch this battle you're
not